[Music]
all right everyone welcome Hamil and I
are absolutely thrilled to be here with
you to basically teach you how to build
the definitive guide to completely
utterly and spectacularly mess up your
AI strategy I actually couldn't have
really wished for a better foil Grace's
lead in than this because we're not just
talking about Minor setbacks here we're
going to take you through a way to
create full-blown company crippling
career ending
failure Grace talked about best
practices but we're here to embrace
worse practices in fact we're going to
make sure you know how to completely
torpedo your projects and ensure you
alienate everyone that you work with how
does that sound it sounds great to me um
so before we begin it might as well
start with some introductions um we Have
No Agenda here it's just a sequence of
steps but I'm Greg I'm an executive
leader and I've spent years in the SE
Suite crafting AI strategies I'm now a
co-founder of an AI startup but
previously I was the chief product
officer at plural site and ex executive
leader at other companies um and I've
had a front row seat to how executive
teams can transform clear strategic
opportunities into labyrinthine
disasters and I'm Hamill I'm a machine
learning engineer and independent
consultant who has worked with many
companies on AI I've witnessed every
conceivable way AI strategies can fail
and I found it really fascinating how
creative people can get with their
failures that's right so you could say
that together we're kind of like the
dream team of disaster we've advised or
maybe we've you know interacted with
representatives from numerous companies
we haven't even have this fancy website
um but for today's presentation we've
decided to live and breathe the great
words of the late Charlie Munger who
said invert always invert so let's get
started all right the first step to
failure is to make sure that you begin
to divide and conquer your own
company this is key if you're destined
to fail you got to embrace the
disconnect between willingness to pay
price and cost the keys to creating
value by contemplating unreasonable
goals and you should especially everyone
here in the audience know by now you you
have to make sure you go and attend
every AI industry conference right but
never go back and talk about what you
learned with your team the point just
like Moses here parting the red SE is to
create impenetrable silos and
incentivize secrecy between your teams
so let's get into
it so I talked about the value stick and
willingness to pay in the the prior
slide but here it's really important for
us to adhere to the anti-value stick you
got to embrace it because it's the
opposite of everything good and useful
when it comes to Value creation and
being strategic and today that's our
guiding principle you might be thinking
that wtp means willingness to pay but
here it's wishful thinking promises you
got to tell your customers that AI is
going to do absolutely everything for
them your new systems are going to write
their emails block their dog solve
climate change and achieve world peace
but don't really worry about the details
just promise the moon you know about
price right well for us that's another
acronym particularly ridiculous
infrastructure costs everywhere
I mean that was a mouthful sorry uh buy
the most expensive gpus don't bother
with any cost benefit analysis just max
out the company credit card think of
this as an investment in something and
cost well it's that Cascade of
spectacular technical debt you're about
to run headlong into um you need to
think about Building Systems so
convoluted so intertwined that even you
as an executive can barely understand it
you know about job security right this
is a key to guaranteeing it think about
it this when it inevitably breaks no
one's there except for you and finally
if you know about value you know about
WTS or willingness to sell for us it's
why this system well the answer and I
mean always is because AI there's never
any further explanation needed no board
is ever going to question you it's like
magic but much more expensive and less
reliable
so step two here is when you start to
Define your strategy right here's the
first key fake any diagnosis you might
be thinking of grab last year's annual
report or operating plan and just start
highlighting random paragraphs
preferably the ones you understand the
least and declare a must fix this don't
bother talking to anyone who actually
does the
work in your guiding policy should be
both incredibly ambiguous and vague
something like become the global AI
leader in everything except don't Define
what everything means that's someone
else's problem totally and your action
plan simple you need an AI powered SEO
tool that guarantees top Google search
results even if you sell garden gnomes
right and a generative art plug-in that
creates nfts of your CEO's cat and of
course an AI drone lunch delivery
service because
Synergy uh announce all of this at your
next company All Hands meeting and you
get both bonus points if you wear a
shiny suit and use the word disruptive
at least a dozen
times and the last point on this slide
is about timelines but timelines are for
companies that intend to finish projects
what we recommend is you Embrace
Perpetual beta just create a massive
backlog in GitHub and stick all those
highlighted Financial reports into that
Greg was mentioning earlier great
strategy but you know what strategy
really works just create a 4,000 page
document that you post in all your slack
channels and just erode people's
willpower to engage with the
material and with these tidal wave of
documents um you know in words Greg
isn't there a strategy that you have
about jargon there certainly is the
point is to communicate in such a way
that nobody understands drown everyone
in a tsunami of jargon say things like
our multimodal agentic Transformer based
system leverages F shot learning and
Chain of Thought reasoning to optimize
the synergistic potential of our Dynamic
hyper hyper parameter space if you say
it with confidence you probably will
have absolutely no idea what you just
said Remember the goal is to look
incredibly smart even if nobody
understands a word you're saying the key
is obfuscation yeah you might be tempted
to do something like defining a very
cogent clear business on a page approach
like in the in in the advantage but
never be too tempted
one of the most effective ways to cause
dysfunction in your organization is to
use jargon
everywhere and use jargon strategically
to hide the jobs to be done for example
I had a mental health client instead of
saying we need to write a prompt we
would just say hey we're building agents
and what that did is it made sure that
the mental health
experts were not in the room and didn't
know how to participate and that's
exactly the result you want that's right
just like haml reduced those mental
health experts mental health I like to
do that as well so instead of saying hey
let's make sure the AI has the right
context I just talk about Rags and don't
say make sure users can trick the AI
into doing something bad just say prompt
injections yeah and the key here is to
encourage Engineers not the people who
might best understand your customers to
write prompts because what could
possibly go
wrong look we know that translating
everyday English language into jargon
can be really difficult so we made this
guide for you and this guide will help
you divide your organizations just like
Greg was talking about earlier just like
Moses the link is right here but
remember making everything even writing
prompts seems super technical and Out Of
Reach for everyone is what you want to
go
for all right just a brief recap we
talked about how to seed your your
division how to start to Define your
strategy how to communicate it now we're
on to mobilization right because you got
to do something with that giant
backlog well some of you might know
about Jeffrey Moore but I've never heard
of him today we're pioneering a very new
revolutionary framework which is about
zoning to lose it's designed
specifically for
failure just randomly assign AI tasks to
people with absolutely no relevant
experience for example Outsource your
data review to Offshore Q&A teams who
have very little context about your
business yeah and most importantly you
might be tempted to use the incubation
Zone to bootstrap new AI ideas but the
goal is to launch from here completely
untested bug written AI chat Bots
directly to your customers as Hamill
mentioned never worry about beta testing
dis disregard quality assurance just
ship it straight to production because
what's the Worst That Could Happen
outside of a potentially career- ending
PR
disaster so if you do it sort of right
should feel something like South Park um
you're going to yank all your best
Engineers from potentially supporting
your Revenue producing products wait a
while and then profit no actually it's
going to feel more like total collapse
and because you're so disorganized we
can now transition
to look and this this point your
organization is in complete disarray but
it's time to do the deed and burn it all
to the
ground so the most effective way to
start doing this is to focus on tools
not processes and those problems that
you created earlier and other ones that
may exist don't analyze them don't try
to understand them just throw tools at
them so if you're rag system isn't
retrieving the right documents just buy
a new more expensive Vector database
yeah and if you need to measure progress
just use every off-the-shelf evaluation
metric you can possibly find never
bother customizing them to your business
needs just blindly trust the numbers
even if they make no
sense oh and like you know we're talking
a lot about agents today if they're not
working just pick a new framework and
vendor F tune without any measurement or
evaluation just assume it's going to be
better because it's kind of like Alchemy
with a lot more electricity
exactly you don't need to look at our
design metrics evals that's a vendor
problem just plug in a tool and it will
solve all your problems Greg I really
love how you demonstrated exactly what
we're going for here with whacko every
time you see a problem hammer it with a
tool if another problem comes up Hammer
that with a tool the same problem comes
again Hammer with a different tool you
get the point yeah H I really appreciate
being meme F to help you get get your
point
across look I want to emphasize you
should adopt a mindset that evals are a
vendor
problem just realize that there should
be a one siiz fits-all
solution let the vendors figure it out
you're too busy being an
executive and if you really want to do
this properly you need to create a
dashboard that looks like this with
every off-the-shelf metric that you can
gather the more metrics the better it
doesn't matter if the metrics track with
outcomes or real failure modes make sure
the numbers are unintelligible so you
don't know the difference between a 3.5
and a
4.5 keep hoarding random metrics until
you find one that's going up and to the
right then you can claim
success and look maybe you might have a
hard time figuring out where you can
come up with these generic metrics but
we got
you just adopt the ones from eval
Frameworks in fact adopt all of them let
your eval metrics guide you blindly and
never ask whether they actually measure
success again the more numbers you have
the better yeah I personally like to
optimize for cosign similarity BL and
Rouge ignoring actual user experience
and I said it once and I'm going to say
it again never cross check with domain
experts or your users because if an LM
says it's accurate who are we to argue
we are their humble servants after all
amen now it's time to unveil the most
potent Technique we have in our toolbox
and it's avoid looking at data seriously
just avoid it keep a blindfold next to
you at all times you Happ to bump into
Data by accident put that blindfold on
yeah data that sounds really messy let's
let a tool handle it because you can
absolutely 100% % trust the ai's output
without ever looking at it yourself
looking at data that's an engineering
problem you're a leader you have more
important strategic things to do like
having meetings about
meetings besides developers they always
have more domain expertise than your
business teams yeah and we know that
ultimately by this point your customers
are really your best Q&A and hopefully
you have lots of them and don't complain
if something is wrong maybe
eventually but more importantly you got
to trust your gut it got you this far in
life right and feelings are always
reliable substitute for data especially
when you're making million-dollar
decisions if you have trouble trusting
your gut just put the blindfold on and
it'll get you right back in touch with
those
feelings so now we know by we know by
now that Engineers are all coding
Wizards and they're going to handle
everything thing it doesn't really
matter if they haven't spoken to a
customer in years because you can
quickly forget about the fact that there
might be simpler options like using
spreadsheets to annotate and look at
data say after me remember this is
beyond me great
advice and just it's not enough for you
not to look at the data you have to make
sure no one else is looking at data and
the best way to do that is to put your
data in complex systems that only
Engineers can access and it's not
available to domain experts right so
like instead of using a simple
spreadsheet or perhaps an air table like
up on the screen as an executive you
should insist on buying a custom data
analysis platform that requires perhaps
a team of phds to operate and understand
remember those bonus points you get more
of them if it takes six months to load
this thing and errors
incessant so there you have it the
ultimate foolproof guide in under 20
minutes to achieving total AI
failure if you follow this advice that
we've given you here meticulously it's
guaranteed that you're going to waste
time resources and alienate all the
people you work with and as far as I'm
concern that's the ultimate success that
you can have sure is so for more advice
it's actually real do visit ai- exec um
we also have an O'Reilly book the same
material coming out February 27th uh and
so while this talk was inverted you know
our lived experience really isn't and
we're always very eager to help you on
your journey so find us after this
presentation the Q&A speak grp thanks so
much
[Music]